on peut pas tout attendre de l'État et
je rejoins ce que disait monsieur
Repentin tout à l'heure sur sur le sujet
je crois que le confinement le covid l'a
montré quand les mères de terrain encore
faut-il qu'il ne fasse pas de de la
politique politicienne et du dogmatisme
veulent se saisir des différentes
initiatives ils sont capables de le
faire avec l'efficacité qu'on a vu sur
les centres de consultation sur les
centres de dépistage sur les centres de
vaccination sur les réouverture de stade
sur les réouverture notamment d'écoles
pour les enfants de de personnels
soignants moi je suis heureux que le
président Vienne parce que il est clair
que l'apaisement du pays passera par les
maires et par les mairies donc arrêtons
d'emmerder les mers simplifions cette
technostructure qui est l'administration
et moi je suis heureux d'entendre le
président de la République nous dire
encore faut-il que les mers et des
projets on l'a vu sur cœur de ville la
ministre cailleux vient de le rappeler
Thierry le sait le sait comme moi quand
on a des projets et bien la
simplification et là mais s'il faut tout
attendre de l'État on aura des réponses
comme moi je l'ai pu l'entendre quand
j'étais mère en disant c'est pas nous de
faire ça les masques c'est pas à nous
bah c'est pas nous mais c'est qui qui va
le faire on attend quoi
[Musique]